welcome back to Piers Morgan uncensored
live from New York City using the Statue
of Liberty there and of course that is
the symbol of freedom and democracy in
the United States and nothing symbolizes
that more than the presidential race my
next guest is shaking up the race for
the White House he's come from pretty
well nowhere to be an Insurgent
Challenger to President Biden and when
he speaks people are listening
he's a Kennedy a controversialist and
now a candidate for president of the
United States
RFK Jr seen by some as the black sheep
of America's most famous political
Dynasty both his uncle President John F
Kennedy and his father Robert F Kennedy
were assassinated Robert Jr blames the
CIA Congress found that yeah it was a
plot it was a conspiracy just as he
blames vaccines for autism and Wi-Fi for
cancer Wi-Fi radiation
is uh it does all kinds of bad things
including causing cancer while some cry
conspiracy many simply see a leader is
ready to rock the establishment and is
paying off 49 of respondents say
Democrat presidential candidate Robert F
Kennedy Jr is viewed favorably by voters
higher than President Biden the wannabe
podcast president is winning over
liberals tired of Biden and Republican
started Trump but is this ripped
Renegade really ready to be president
well Robert F Kennedy Jr joins me now
great to see you great to meet you great
to meet you
um I interviewed you a few weeks ago at
the very start of all this I gotta say
you're having a great race I mean this
is really for you I would say of all the
candidates on either side you're the one
getting most attention
yeah I mean it's been uh so far so good
I'm um
I think I me and my whole team are very
happy with how things be going we're
getting tremendous traction all over the
country our polling data shows uh you
know me
um surging oh we're happy
let me ask you because viewers were
asking me last time what's up with his
voice they didn't know they didn't know
you they hadn't heard you speak before
let's talk about that what is the issue
with your voice I had a very I had a
very very strong voice
until I was 42 years old in 1996 I had
an injury uh that caused a neurological
disorder called spasmodic dystonia
and it makes my voice like this I cannot
listen to my voice I when I go home I
will not listen to this program really I
can't do it and I feel sorry for the
people in your audience who have to
listen to me but this is the best I've
got right now but I am
you know I went over with my wife Cheryl
Hines to do a surgery in Kyoto in Japan
about uh eight months ago and it made my
voice a lot more reliable and now I'm
doing a bunch of alternative uh sort of
therapies that make it I I think they're
making it a lot stronger so we'll see
what happens because he must be when
you're on the trail like this you're
doing so many interviews and and
stumpings and so on I mean you use your
voice all the time does it worry you
that it may just sort of pack up or no
because my voice actually doesn't get
weaker when I use it it gets stronger
really yeah because it's not it's not
tissue injury so my my you know my vocal
cords are very very strong it's just the
neurological signals that are being sent
to them or are telling them to tighten
up all the time and it makes my voice
Gravely but
I can talk 20 hours a day and I've
always won't wear out so I'm not worried
about that but well I don't like the way
it sounds and I you know I apologize to
everybody any apologies necessarily I
think people are just curious
um and actually it's what comes out of
your voice it's more interesting and
more relevant to the fact that you want
to be president you come from American
royalty the Kennedy family
obviously they've had a president
they've had others who were running for
president uh why do you want to be
president what's your burning
Focus here as to what you know I I was I
did not spent a lifetime
of thinking about Someday I'm gonna run
for president I a bunch of things happen
particularly since covered over
the last 18 years I've been subject to a
lot of censorship on the issue of
vaccines so most people if they you know
call me people call me anti-vaxine but
I'm not a vaccine
and I'm called that in order to silence
me and I've been silenced in you know
many many ways for for the last 18 years
but particularly since covid
when there was Blanket censorship around
the country
um and in the UK and everywhere people
you know doctors who are reporting uh
injuries and their patients from the
vaccines or reporting success from early
treatments like Ivermectin and
hydroxychlorine we're all silenced
because that was not part of the
political narrative
and the frustration that censorship and
now you know there was a case that uh
155 page opinion that was issued earlier
this week
by a judge
um in Missouri
um about uh enjoying the White House
from censoring people anymore and it's a
large part of that decision is about the
censorship of Me by the White House I
was the first person censored so
Biden came into office on January 21st
2021 and on January 23rd
Twitter and the other social media sites
refused or
received orders from the White House to
de-platform me and then three when I
certainly think that a lot of the
censorship that went on to drink over on
many fronts was completely wrong looking
back over it and shouldn't have been
happening let me just ask you have you
ever had a vaccine for anything
have I had vaccines I I was fully
compliant
what have you had in your life I mean
vaccines well I had all the vaccines you
know when I was a kid I took the three
vaccines with that then required now my
kids generation there were 72 vaccines
required in this country 72 dose of 16
vaccines
but I was traveling a lot as a kid I
went to Africa I Latin America and
everything so I received an entire
battery that you used to receive so I
probably received more vaccines than
most people in my generation and your
kids will have vaccines my my kids were
all fully vaccinated now so you're not
intrinsically anti-vaccine oh I was
never any vaccine all I want is is the
safety signs
I think that we should have
placebo-controlled trials which are
required for every other medical product
prior to licensing vaccines and
unfortunately vaccines are exempt from
those they're the only medicine or
medical products that are exempt from
pre-licensing safety trials and you know
and therefore we do not know
what the risk profile for any of these
products are and we do not know for any
particular of those 72 doses
whether they are averting more problems
they're causing and I just think we
ought to know that I also don't believe
that we should have mandates I think you
know matters the government should not
be well I certainly think once the once
it was established that you could
transmit the virus covid whether you've
been vaccinated or not then it becomes a
personal choice I think the once that
was established to me that argument
about mandate it was was nonsensical
let's take a short break I don't spend
the whole interview talking about
vaccines you tend to do that a lot
probably not a choice
all through choice so we've done that
let's come back and talk about about you
I know you're a falconer you're like
white water rafting you like a thrill
and a and a danger in your life I want
to get into that after the break more
from Robert Kennedy Jr welcome back to
Facebook live from New York City I'll
move my guest Robert F Kennedy Junior
what was the best and worst thing about
being a Kennedy
I I I you know what I think the good
vastly outweighs the bad
uh I I don't I don't see anything to
complain about honestly you know I think
there's been so many I feel so blessed I
feel a privilege to be a member of this
family and
you know not only because of the sort of
the the cash and prize and the
connections that you have in the acts as
and the education and then it's you know
I have a 11 brothers and sisters and 29
cousins and we all
love each other and you argue a lot
right I mean yeah we were we were
trained to argue
um and my my grandfather did that with
his nine kids
you would make them you know every night
at the dinner table take opposite uh
I'll do that with my kids I think it's
healthy yeah
I think it is too and I you know I think
you need we never we need to learn to
talk with each other dispute to have
conversation and discourse without
hating each other I totally agree this
this you know I came from an era when I
was young you go down the pub and you'd
have an argument and you'd buy each
other a pint and that was it you didn't
fall out with people because you
disagree with them well you know my
Uncle Teddy Kennedy who is in the senate
for 50 years and he has more legislation
attached to his name than any senator in
the United States history and the reason
for that is he was he had so many
friends on the Republican side of the
aisle
he'd come home on weekends to the cape
where we all live in kind of a communal
group and he'd bring Warren hatch who is
you know to us kind of a right-wing
Darth Vader
and spent uh you know we'd spend the
weekend on a boat with him and you know
to see Teddy laughing with him and
really just enjoying and loving that's
how he should be it's how he should be
um and he never compromised his values
right but you don't have to but you can
certainly have your views challenged by
people that don't agree without losing
your mind let me ask you I mean you
Robert you were nine when your uncle
John F Kennedy was assassinated you were
14 when your father
was assassinated they're very formative
years I've got three sons who both you
know all three of them came through
those ages very formative years for such
cataclysmic things to happen what what
impact do you think those two huge
events had on your life
well I you know I think they were
National traumas
and they were part of the national
traumas you know they were basically
kind of five or six dramas uh Martin
Luther King's death my uncle my father
the Vietnam War
uh the and uh 911 and covet that pushed
our country in a bad Direction down the
road to be you know the military
industrial complex and and it becoming
kind of a surveillance late at home
but for my own personal point of view
you know my mom told us something when
we were really um told me something on
one of my brothers died
and I said to her does that that's the
hole that they leave in you when they
died is that ever again any smaller
and she said no it never gets any
smaller but our job is to grow ourselves
bigger around the whole by taking the
best parts of that the best virtues of
that person who died
and trying to incorporate them into your
own life into your own character
as part of the morning process and that
builds you bigger as a person so the
whole proportionately gets smaller and I
think all of us
and my family tried to do that we were
also schools from oh you're very little
to never complain you know that my
mother would say to us
there are kids in Harlem and in watts
and in Compton who lose their mother and
their father and they don't have the
family we have and they don't have the
educational opportunities and you know
everybody takes their licks in life and
you know they you have to have a mission
and you have to keep moving
take the best parts of that person let
me ask you about your father then do you
I mean he was for many people the
greatest president America sadly never
had hi Uncle oh my father your father
your father
what do you think you've gained from him
and do you feel his Spirit guiding you
now as you run for president yeah I mean
I I've spent a lot of time
I think unlike other members of my
family who are who many of them are so
shattered even to this day that they
can't
um really think about my dad's uh you
know death or my uncle jack
um but I've spent a lot of time kind of
reading all the literature and studying
their lives and I
uh I'm constantly
delighted and and surprised by how much
of um of their uh their values have
studied we have wisdom at the test of
time
and I think you know my campaign right
now is about recalling America to those
values and what are they summarize them
well you know all of the kind of
Traditional Values the Democratic party
which are free speech you know A love
for the Constitution
um a uh uh protecting the environment or
the purple mountains Majesty for our
children
protecting that government has a overall
old protective rights of minorities and
for uh people who are underrepresented
in the political process
um women's right bodily autonomy you
know
um that that
smaller government is and and more
freedom is always better the word
liberal means freedom and it's uh it's
it and that this idea
that democracy and that you know from a
totalitarian system Fosters human growth
and human creativity so a love of the
Arts which is the highest aspiration of
uh you know of democracy my uncle used
to say that
um that you know nobody really remembers
the names the generals and the
balconesian wars and the and the battles
you know
but everybody remembers the the poems
Vasquez and the plays of Sophocles and
um and the art and the sculpture and the
and uh you know and the literature the
beauty of the of the uh of the
architecture of ancient Greece and that
that really is the ultimate aspiration
of a Democratic Society
to create things that are enduring and
that elevate the human Spirit let's take
a short break come back and talk about
what Arts you're good at then because I
know it involves whitewater kayaking and
falconry what else do you do Robert F
Kennedy Junior we'll find out after the
break I'll go back to Perth we're going
to send it looking at the Empire State
Building here in Manhattan in New York
and I'm still with the presidential
candidate Robert F Kennedy Jr well we
left the viewers on a cliffhanger what
are your artistic bents what are you
what do you find your cultural solace
well what do you mean I mean I you know
I I
am not particularly talented as an
artist let me put that out there that's
not a big disappointment people but you
know I love like I'm I have eclectic
days in music and I love
uh art and art history and going to
museums and you know so but I I I I
admire it but I'm not very good at it
but falconry is a big thing in your life
yeah I what do you get from falconry
I have always had an affinity for the
outdoors and for nature and for me you
know I
read when my uncle was in that white
house and a lot of people talking about
Camelot and I read th whites well the
once in Future King it's a British uh
Falconer and an incredible writer
and it's about the story of young King
Arthur and there was a chapter there on
falconry on training the Hawks which was
a very popular you know in the Middle
Ages it was the most popular sport
and when I read that chapter I fell in
love with it and I became obsessed with
it and as it turned out there was a guy
who lived about a mile from my house who
was one of the great pioneers of
American falconry
his name is Alvin and I and my father
knew about him he was uh designing jets
for the Pentagon but the uh my father
knew about him because the state
department whenever they were visiting
Arab dignitaries
they would send them to this guy's house
because they are observed crazy for
falconry
um and so I was able because of my
father's contact with him I was able to
Apprentice under him and I learned Falk
great beginning when I was nine years
what's he giving you falconry it's uh
you know you're it's like being you're
you're with a predatory bird and you're
hunting in the wild usually with two
birds at a time
and it's like being allowed they don't
change their behavior any any they're
doing nothing that they wouldn't do in
the wild
but you're observing them close up so
it's like being allowed to hunt with a
wolf back you know where and who
wouldn't want to do that you see a an
analogy to what you're doing now to the
the other Democratic candidates not
really are you hunting Joe Biden down
like a wolf you know I I
preserving the environment and giving
other kids the opportunity to do
to enjoy the richness of those kind of
experience of the outdoors is one that
I'd say the spirit tip of my campaign
that we need to you know we've helped us
through your campaign is your your
youthful vigor and we've seen some uh
tremendous videos of you here in action
working out here which has got everyone
going um I mean obviously we we look at
this and we see a man in Peak physical
condition
um congratulations but we also are
reminded of uh President Biden's but
let's put it kindly lack of comparative
physical condition How concerned are you
never mind the race but how concerned
are you when you see President Biden now
in public the sheer volume of missteps
both verbal and physical does it concern
you as an American the president seems
to be I I don't really think that I have
any
uh additional wisdom to contribute to
that debate I I think that I I don't I
haven't seen President Biden in a couple
of years
and I don't know you know I see I saw
him trip on the stage but you know
anybody can as you know anybody can trip
on a stage and uh and so I don't really
know what his condition is there are
worrying
um you know videos and stuff but uh but
do you sense that he may not actually
run in 2024 when it comes to it and is
that why you think you actually have a
real chance of potentially becoming the
Democrat nominee I think I have a chance
of becoming the Democratic nominee
because my numbers
are better at beating Republicans than
him so and I think that's what the
demonstration should the party make him
stand aside for you well I you know
that's first of all that's not going to
happen
oh it doesn't that have to happen to let
you no no I mean I I have to win some
primaries and you think you can actually
beat it I think I can beat him in the
primaries I'm going to be incredible
well I'd be pretty much unprecedented if
you do that right to an incumbent
president it's uh I I think I think
Reagan did that against uh Gerald Ford
right
oh but um yeah I mean it's unusual but
you know my father ran against his
incoming president and he would have won
um and uh you know my Uncle Teddy ran
against incumbent President Carter and
and lost and do you actually believe one
uh he won something like 37 States you
actually believe in
2024 when we get to December January you
will be the person I on inauguration day
addressing the American people okay I'm
going to be very uh objective about this
but I'm telling you that we have a few
seconds left if I had put money and bet
on any candidate I would put it on me
that's good enough Robert Kennedy Junior
a great pleasure to meet you I was a
gambling ad what I'm a Gambling Man a
mother pot myself good to see you